when you get down to it the games we
play in and joy all have an element of
strategy whether that's a serious one
it's a good change the reaper generally
doing a little bit better in this third
[Music]
while picking your approach is part of
the game some tactics are seen as too
controversial too cheesy purchased alive
out of all this [__] [__] this game
right now and like it's delicious
real-life counterpart gaming cheese is
varied versatile and very much a product
of the culture from which it derives a
man wants the cheese before long besides
the obvious cheese like meaning it looks
like the term cheesy began to mean cheap
or inferior around the turn of the 20th
century in the United States but in
gaming the earliest existing examples
actually refer to Street Fighter 2 and
before we get too far into this keep in
mind that the term has been used loosely
and differently in a variety of games
we're gonna look at a spread of fine
gaming cheeses in Street Fighter the
term called attention to strategies that
were seen as disproportionately powerful
compared to the skill required to use
them like spamming the same move
repeatedly relying on a cheap strategy
like that was in most gaming communities
seen as dishonorable and in 1990
phors bizarre post-apocalyptic fighting
game primal rage Atari games added a no
cheese feature which may be the first
time that dishonorable play was
specifically called cheese in game and
not just by its community no cheese no
cheese I think it's because I was like
doing the same thing the no cheese
mechanic was triggered when a player
used the same move too many times in a
combo or tried to throw an opponent who
was still in block stun resulting in the
no cheese notice appearing on screen
when no cheese is active the offenders
repeated move no longer damages their
opponent and if it's used during a
chained attack causes the combo to be
dropped by the way if you can't tell yet
this game is [__] crazy and extremely
edgy for the 90s just look at this [__]
[Applause]
now that's [__] up anyways stephen
reason burger was an Associate Producer
on primal rage and he told me in an
email that no cheese was meant to
prevent infinite combos but also that
the idea acted as a sort of substitute
for just making cheese strategies
ineffective and this is the first
important part of cheese as games became
more well balanced a cheesy tactic
increasingly referred to a shallow
strategy something that wasn't really
consistently effective against
experienced players following primal
rage capcom put a cheese icon in Street
Fighter Alpha 2 that appeared when you
wanna round by defeating a blocking
opponent with chip damage from a super
or special move across the rathaus gets
punished for it nice call well the
concept of cheese and gaming may have
been well known in 90's fighting games
the term exploded in popularity with
Starcraft and Starcraft 2 the latter
specifically popularizing it in the West
four lanes six lanes didn't cancel the
shape so it looks like we are gonna have
some sort of cheese on our hands much
like in fighting games cheese strategies
were frowned upon in StarCraft but what
made them different in blizzards RTS is
they relied upon a lack of information
either not knowing what was happening or
not knowing how to counter it checks
tools the doors of his base doesn't stop
he really thinks he's safe right now he
is not expecting this proxy but here he
goes
well you see it he sees it but is it too
late Apollo Starcraft cheese is usually
an all-in proposition you either live by
it or you die by it and its success is
entirely dependent on how prepared for
it your opponent is now this guy has
balls of steel Otto --ss a bat number
Waddy try something incredibly risky
because if it's scouted and spotted it
is very easy to handle and you ask do
you think he's gonna do it again I said
no I think a lot of other people would
say no but he's doing the same again
still gonna be in a lot of trouble even
if he holds it all for now
yeah he's got to be careful he's gonna
lose the mothership cool the soca pops
out Gee Gee
we've been around Starcraft competition
for years people have loved this moves
Koreans in particularly either
industries are started with some pretty
ballsy cheese just to throw off their
opponent but to do it twice is that
insanity or is that bravery and with the
MOBA trend in full swing towards the end
of the 2000s cheese began to develop
more unique flavors from
suspicious-looking team comp fromage
wait a minute all right so we got a lock
in Leblanc
just jungle - you all right well the TF
is going for the early gank he went
crunch in the red
going to Kiki's with the jungle Twisted
Fate too unpredictable game-changing
Strax Oh Greta we've seen some fun
cheesy strats other lines from time to
time and this is something this is it
this is Manila major alliance yeah let's
do it
they plan they plug the rat dirt every
now here we go
VG are like guys what are we gonna do
about this I mean Ted how it actually
just died - Shadow Demon getting the
chills Javy gm's life following DOTA
allstars valve even went as far as
making cheese an in-game item in dota 2
cheese is a powerful consumable drop by
Roshan after his second death and
everytime thereafter
Rochelle's cheese restores a sizeable
portion of its indulges health and mana
when used making it pretty Gouda relax
it was just a pun shut the [__] up okay
shut the [__] up today the MOBA genre
has become massive and it's
predominantly here and in StarCraft that
the term remains in use but some argue
that cheese and MOBAs especially at the
competitive level
has become an unnecessarily derogatory
term for what would otherwise be called
a pocket strap something innovative that
catches the opponent off guard
essentially one players pocket strat
could be another player's cheese
but as long as we play games there will
be those who gravitate towards cheap
easy to use strategies and well not all
of us may like cheese it's become an
accepted part of every competitive game
but you know what's not acceptable
I specifically asked for an assorted
cheese platter and you gave me this
these are like the Protoss Canon rush of
dairy products did you see that one of
the fatalities is he just makes their
ghost go into heaven I don't know why
and then one of que haces finishers I
don't if you say he just literally jumps
into a lake I mean we can swim like a
probably yeah butterfly shut up I hope I
wouldn't drown I can swim I don't know
what it's called but I can swim dude I'm
not gonna drown